when nickelodeon's icarly premiered in
2007
it was an instant hit the television
show followed miranda cosgrove's carly
shea and jeanette mccurdy's sam puckett
as they created a fictional web series
the web series itself was produced by
the pals
tech whiz and perpetually grumpy best
friend freddy benson
played by a young nathan kress the show
had six seasons a spin-off named sam and
cat
a made-for-tv film and a crossover film
that included the cast of one of
nickelodeon's other hit shows victorious
the momentum behind the tween show
should have catapulted all the stars to
fame
and though miranda cosgrove has been in
a variety of acting projects since then
nathan cress all but disappeared from
the spotlight following the 2012
conclusion of the show i goodbye
crest has not landed any major roles
since so what happened to freddy besides
some weird fan interactions
did you have any bizarre fan
interactions yeah i had a girl puke
like at the sight of you from excitement
or a little
still unknown miranda cosgrove had
already found success before the show by
starring in 2003's
school of rock alongside jack black and
she was savvy enough to not put
all her eggs in one basket as icarly
filmed cosgrove
booked roles in feature films notably
voicing the character of margot and the
despicable me franchise
in contrast kress started out by booking
roles on other teen sitcoms including
the suite life with zack and cody when
he landed the role of freddy crest
booked almost
no other major projects throughout the
entirety of the show's original run
exceptions to this were one guest
starring role on csi crime scene
investigation
in 2010 and a role in 2008's gym teacher
the movie opposite christopher maloney
when icarly wrapped crest took on guest
starring roles for a few short-lived
television shows including the jeanette
mccurdy spin-off sam and cat
three years after playing freddie on
icarly cress's name can be seen in the
credits of two other network shows
henry danger and game shakers his
experience as a faux producer
must have helped him get familiar with
work behind the camera
he directed 11 episodes for henry danger
nickelodeon's comedy series about a
teenager who gets a part-time job
helping a superhero
he also took the director's reigns for
six episodes of game shakers which
follows the fictional story of two
wildly successful teens this time in the
world of game making
kress has also been charismatic enough
to return as himself in both series as
well as a number of nickelodeon specials
including throwback with nickelodeon
which focuses on the nostalgia of old
nick shows and the after party a
post-prime time talk show
cress had a role in the 2014 fictional
disaster film into the storm
he began dating his cast mate from the
movie london elise moore and they
married and in 2017 they had their first
child while in december 2020 cress
announced via his instagram that the
family was now expecting their second
child his podcast radioactive dads
focuses on working and raising children
in hollywood
the show features chris his co-host
brett davern of mtv's awkward and other
celebrity parents
the hosts chat about working on set and
discuss their evolving perspective as
millennials moving into the parenting
phase of their lives
cress is a big advocate for parenting he
even joined a movement
entitled man enough led by author justin
baldoni according to the program the
movement is
founded on the belief that by undefining
traditional roles and traits of
masculinity
men will be able to realize their
potential as humans and their capacity
for connection
however busy he is as a parent he still
hasn't stopped working
in 2020 et online reported the viacom
cbs announcement that a reboot of icarly
would premiere on the network's
streaming service paramount plus
the new show will appropriately be
called icarly revival
the reboot sees the return of miranda
cosgrove as well as jerry traynor
who played carly's brother spencer
however jeanette mccurdy has announced
that she will not be returning
in january 2021 cress posted a photo
from the set of the show that features
the three returning actors smiling into
the camera
the show premiered june 17th and is
loaded with all those nostalgic feels
that you've been missing
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite unheralded actors are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you